Hallo zusammen! Heute gibt's mal wieder ein türkisches Rezept!
Wir machen Lahana Sarmasi.
Das ist ein türkisches Wort und bedeutet übersetzt sowas wie Weißkohl-Rollen, -Rouladen..
Das ist ein vegetarisches bzw. auch veganes Rezept, allerdings serviere ich das später auch mit Joghurt - das liebe ich!
[Hamza] Das gibt's auch im Arabischen!
[Kiki] Ja, das gibt's auch im Arabischen. Wie heißt das bei euch?
[Hamza] Malfouf!
[Kiki] Malfouf!
[Kiki] Bestimmt wird das im arabischen Raum anders gemacht als bei den Türken.
[Hamza] Kann ich mir vorstellen, ja!
Aber weißt du was cool wäre? Dass wir mal die Mama fragen - also die Schwiegermama - wie sie das macht
und dann zeigen wir auch mal die arabische Variante. Oder sie macht direkt ein Video mit mir!
Schreibt mal in die Kommentare wenn ihr das feiern würdet! Dann muss ich sie nur noch überreden, dass sie das macht!
Also wir fangen jetzt direkt an mit der "Füllung".
Es wird eine Reisfüllung. Das gibt's aber auch mit Hackfleisch, ich mache das heute ohne Hackfleisch.
Und den Reis - das ist ein super wichtiger Schritt! - den müsst ihr vorab unter normal lauwarmem Wasser abspülen
damit die Stärkeschicht soweit es geht entfernt wird und der Reis später nicht mehr klebt. Das habe ich hier schon erledigt.
Das erkennt ihr ganz gut auch an dem Wasser: wenn das klar unten rauskommt, dann ist es genau richtig.
So, den Reis habe ich mir in eine große Schüssel gegeben und da gebe ich jetzt sehr klein gehackte Zwiebeln dazu
und eigentlich wird echt nur alles mit den Händen verknetet für die Füllung.
Als nächstes kommen Tomatenmark und Paprikamark dazu.
Es ist jetzt nicht schlimm wenn ihr eins von den beiden grad nicht da habt, dann tauscht das einfach aus
und so finde ich es persönlich aber am leckersten.
Das gebe ich jetzt direkt mit dazu, einfach mit den Händen.
So, was jetzt auch ganz typisch ist - übrigens: Ich schreibe euch alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben wie immer unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Da habe ich sogar - obwohl im Türkischen ganz normal ist, dass man mit Tassen und Gläsern abwiegt, habe ich euch die ganz genauen Grammangaben abgewogen.
So, was ganz typisch ist sind Petersilie und Dill.
Das werde ich jetzt hier sehr fein hacken und auch noch mit dazu geben.
An Gewürzen geben wir Salz dazu, Pfeffer, wer mag, etwas Sumak.
Außerdem ein bisschen Pul Biber (Vorsicht, das ist scharf!) und ganz wichtig: Kreuzkümmel.
Warum brauchen wir Kreuzkümmel? Das möchte ich nochmal ganz kurz erklären.
Weil Weißkohl ist ja, wie wir eigentlich alle schonmal so gehört haben, aufblähend
und Kreuzkümmel wirkt da eben entgegen. Daher darauf bitte nicht verzichten!
Beim Sumak muss ich sagen: Macht das gerne mal rein, probiert das aus. Das gibt noch so eine richtig richtig schöne Säure.
[Kiki] Und jetzt kommt eigentlich nur noch...
[Hamza] Kurze Anmerkung!
[Hamza] Bei Hummus macht man das auch!
[Kiki] Ja, das stimmt. Bei Hummus macht man das auch bei Kichererbsen, genau.
So, und jetzt kommt Olivenöl dazu.
Nehmt da bitte ein gutes Olivenöl, das wirkt sich enorm auf den Geschmack aus.
Später brauchen wir Olivenöl auch nochmal und das wird einfach auch -
Ich glaube - ich will mich jetzt nicht vertun aber ich glaube bei der albanischen Variante von diesem Gericht (mit Sicherheit sind das auch wieder ganz andere Gewürze)
macht man auch ganz viel Olivenöl rein und das finde ich macht's immer so ein bisschen aus.
Also Olivelnöl mit dazu geben und nicht geizen! Aber ich schreib euch auch die ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten rein.
Und dann einfach mit den sauberen Händen richtig schön durchkneten.
[Hamza] Türkisches Gericht mit italienischem Olivenöl!
Ja, das ist jetzt unser italienisches Olivenöl!
Das palästinensische ist aktuell leider ausverkauft aber ich werde euch alle Gewürze und das Öl etc. auch unten in die Videobeschreibung verlinken.
[Hamza] Wie- machst du die ganze Flasche leer oder was?!
[Kiki] So, jetzt. Ja!
[Hamza] Das ist krass
[Hamza] Das ist so viel!
[Kiki] Ja, das - vertrau mir! Das sieht nur so viel aus!
So, das ist meine Füllung. Die habe ich jetzt nur einmal umgefüllt und die riecht schon richtig richtig lecker!
So, die gebe ich jetzt kurz an die Seite. Es gibt übrigens auch Varianten für dieses Rezept, da kocht man den Reis vor.
Bin ich jetzt nicht so ein großer Fan von. Also kann man natürlich machen, aber...warum?
Nimmt einfach viel mehr Zeit in Anspruch und am Ende ist das Ergebnis trotzdem mega mega lecker!
So, und jetzt brauchen wir einen Weißkohl. Da müssen wir den harten Strunk einmal entfernen
und anschließend werden wir das für ein paar Sekunden in kochendes Wasser geben damit sie weich werden aber das zeige ich euch nochmal.
So, jetzt ist es ein bisschen tricky aber eigentlich ist es auch einfach
denn wir müssen jetzt vom Weißkohl die Blätter irgendwie runterbekommen.
Und Weißkohl - wenn ihr die Blätter selber runterzieht, dann brechen sie und sie müssen jetzt einfach weich werden.
Dafür habe ich hier einen großen Topf mit heißem Wasser. Das habe ich jetzt einmal aufgekocht und dann wieder runtergeschaltet.
Da habe ich dann den Weißkohl mit reingegeben, und wenn ihr mit einem Löffel auch immer wieder heißes Wasser in diese Zwischenschichten gebt, dann lösen sich die Blätter wie von alleine.
Also hier hat das ganz gut geklappt. Die sind dann so weich, dass man sie einrollen kann.
Wenn ihr einen Kohl da habt, wo sich einige Blätter auch mit der Hand lösen, dann nehmt die Blätter und tut sie für 20sek oder 15sek in kochendes Wasser.
Wichtig ist jetzt einfach nur, dass sie so weich werden, dass wir sie dann aufrollen können.
Denn wenn sie noch hart sind, dann brechen sie und das ganze Rezept funktioniert nicht.
Und so nehme ich mir jetzt von außen immer und immer wieder Blätter ab, so lange bis nichts mehr übrig ist.
[Hamza] Ist ein bisschen tricky aber es funktioniert!
[Kiki] Ja, ist ein bisschen tricky aber es klappt!
Jetzt geht's ans Befüllen und das mache ich indem ich hier einfach mit 'nem Teigrädchen den harten Strunk erstmal entferne.
[Hamza] Pizzarädchen!
Pizzarädchen, Teigrädchen...alles dat gleiche!
So. Weil den brauchen wir nicht. Den müsst ihr aber auch nicht wegschmeißen weil essen kann man das ja!
Also den braucht ihr nicht wegschmeißen. Ich lege den gleich - also alle so Reste, die ich nicht brauche,
lege ich gleich auf den Topfboden damit nix anklebt.
Also wir hatten gerade schon die Diskussion: Hamza meinte Malfouf, also die arabische Variante wird viel größer gemacht
[Hamza] Viel größer, genau!
Ich kenne das so jetzt von meiner Mutter, dass wir eher mittelgroß - also es ist ein bisschen größer als Sarma.
[Hamza] Du hast hier welche vorbereitet.
[Kiki] Ich hab da schon welche vorbereitet, genau.
[Hamza] Das ist so wie Sarma finde ich!
[Hamza] Aber bei uns sind die auch nochmal doppelt so - doppelt so dick auch!
[Kiki] Ich muss sagen Sarma ist bei uns noch ein bisschen - also eigentlich halb so dünn!
Jetzt nehme ich mir hier einen guten Teelöffel..
[Hamza] Weißt du wieso? Die arabische Sarma ist auch ein bisschen dicker als die türkische, deswegen!
[Kiki] Ja bei euch ist alles irgendwie so ein bisschen anders aber alles lecker!
So und jetzt einfach einrollen. Ich sehe zu, dass die "Adern" sage ich mal innen sind und dann einfach einrollen!
So, jetzt habe ich alle Weißkohlblätter aufgerollt und nehme mir einen Topf.
Ich habe jetzt hier einen relativ kleinen Topf. Das reicht übrigens so als Beilage für 4 Portionen oder als Hauptspeise für 2-3 Portionen würde ich sagen.
Und jetzt nehme ich mir so die überschüssigen Blätter, die ich jetzt grad einfach nicht gebrauchen konnte weil sie zu klein sind oder zu hart etc.
und gebe die jetzt auf den Boden des Topfes.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass jetzt nichts anbrennen wird aber wenn man mal doch vergisst reinzugucken kann das sein,
dass die Kohlblätter unten anpappen und das könnte man jetzt ganz einfach eben vermeiden.
Und dann schichten wir ganz einfach.
So, jetzt kommen die allerallerletzen Schritte, ich hab schon richtig Hunger! Ich freu mich riesig, die nachher zu verdrücken.
Ich hab jetzt noch Paprikamark mit ordentlich Olivenöl vermengt,
gebe da jetzt noch - das ist abgekochtes Wasser - gebe das jetzt noch mit dazu
einfach damit sich keine großen Klumpen bilden, dass sich das gut aufgelöst.
Und dann geben wir das nochmal als Geschmacksträger auf die Weißkohlrouladen.
So!
Und da gebe ich jetzt so viel Wasser dazu bis es ungefähr 1cm über den Rouladen steht.
Jetzt mit einem schweren Teller das Ganze quasi runterdrücken
und jetzt müssen wir das Ganze mit geschlossenem Deckel bei niedriger Stufe garen lassen.
So, 1½h später!
Mein Reis ist jetzt gar. Ihr dürft euch auch zwischendurch mal eine Roulade rausnehmen und einfach mal reingucken, ob der Reis gar ist.
Und ich hab noch mehr Tipps für euch! Wenn ihr die beherzigt klappt auch alles, versprochen!
Also Tipp #1: Ihr dürft auch ruhig ähm..den...Teller auch wegnehmen!
Also es dient wirklich nur der Beschwerung am Anfang und vor allem dass die Rouladen nicht aufgehen.
Die sollen am Anfang schön gefestigt sein und später dürft ihr das auch gerne rausnehmen, vor allem wenn ihr merkt, dass das Wasser nicht verdampfen kann.
Das war nämlich anfangs - also damals, als ich das quasi gelernt habe von meiner Mama - mein Fehler
und das möchte ich euch jetzt weitergeben.
Außerdem ist es auch gar nicht schlimm, wenn das Wasser nicht komplett verdampft, euer Reis aber gar ist. Das macht überhaupt nichts.
Und noch ein Tipp: Ihr dürft auch gerne kochendes Wasser nachgießen.
Wenn ihr euch nicht sicher seid ob das Wasser heiß genug ist,
dann könnt ihr auch ganz am Anfang wenn noch alles roh ist das Wasser schön aufkochen und köcheln lassen
damit ihr euch der Temperatur wirklich sicher seid.
Danach reicht wirklich garen bei einer niedrigen Temperatur.
Ich muss sagen ich habe 9 Stufen am Herd und ich bin die ganze Zeit geswitcht zwischen 4 und 5.
Und jetzt ist das Essen serviert!
Und ihr dürft auch das Ganze auch ruhig nochmal ½h stehen lassen, dann sitzt alles nochmal schön
Und dann könnt ihr das Ganze mit Joghurt servieren.
Also ich find sie - ich hab grad schon einen probiert - die sind perfekt geworden!
Und für den Joghurt verrühre ich ganz einfach Joghurt mit Knoblauch und Salz - das war's!
Soo! Lecker lecker!
[Hamza] Ich glaub man kann aus mir eine Meme machen, ich schwör's dir!
[Kiki] So, Hamza probiert!
[Kiki] Darf ich kurz was sagen? Darf ich kurz was sagen?
[Kiki] Ihr müsst euch vorstellen: Hamzas Mama macht die so, so lecker!
[Kiki] Ich liebe die!
[Kiki] Du kennst sie nur auf arabische Art und jetzt kommen sie eher auf die türkische Art!
[Hamza] Ich riech's schon! Das riecht stark nach Paprikapulver, Pul Biber.
[Kiki] Ich hab ein bisschen Pul Biber reingetan!
[Kiki] Aber Paprikamark ist da ganz viel drin!
[Hamza] Aha! Ich weiß gar nicht, wie meine Mutter das macht. Ob sie das mit Paprikamark macht..aber ist auch egal.
[Hamza] Unterschied zwischen meiner Mutter auf jeden Fall: die sind viel dicker. Also meine Mama macht die viel dicker und ein bisschen länger.
[Hamza] Aber ich glaub ich find das sogar besser so, sonst muss man ein bisschen kämpfen mit denen.
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Ich glaub mit denen kann man so einen Schwaps und die sind im Mund, oder? Einen Schwaps?
[Kiki] Ich glaub 2!
[Hamza] Einen Schwaps? Einen Haps!
[Kiki] Einen Haps!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Oooh! Schaut euch mal an was Kiki da hat! Uuuh, richtig edel, ne?
[Kiki] Jaa!
[Hamza] Da hat sie einmal so einen Wischer gemacht hier unten, ne?
[Kiki] Einen Wischer!
[Hamza] Wow, wow, wow! Respekt!
[Hamza] So..probieren wir's mal. Ich will das einmal ohne Joghurt essen.
[Kiki] Ja, ja, ja! Ohne Joghurt!
[Kiki] *lacht* Nein! Nein, das ist schlechte Werbung für mich!
[Hamza] Nein, das ist typisch! Das ist bei meiner Mutter auch so. Das ist normal!
[Kiki] Eigentlich kannst du sie auch in die Hand nehmen, jetzt mal ehrlich!
[Hamza] Ja!
[Hamza] Beim Türkischen: Man merkt echt, dass es ein bisschen mehr paprika-lastig ist als die arabische Variante und noch ein bisschen mehr olivenöl-lastig.
[Hamza] Aber vom Geschmack her ist es schon sehr ähnlich und es schmeckt - also...
[Hamza] Kiki du kannst das öfters machen, ganz ehrlich!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Ich war schon beeindruckt von diesem Geruch weil ich dachte grad: "Es riecht so wie bei meiner Mutter Zuhause!"
[Kiki] M-hm!
[Hamza] "Irgendwas erinnert mich gerade an Zuhause!"
[Hamza] Du hast es glaub ich geschafft, du hast es geschafft! Also ich finde das sehr lecker. Wie gesagt: Es ist ein bisschen ölig.
[Kiki] Ich wollte das so. Weil ich liebe diesen Olivenöl-Geschmack, der darf bei mir nicht zu kurz kommen!
[Hamza] Ich glaube das ist der einzige Unterschied zur arabischen Variante. Aber vom Geschmack her: Mega, super!
[Hamza] Ich liebe die weil die so einfach zu essen sind! Ich mag die mehr als Sarma also Wara9 al 3inab weil ich finde da ist noch ein bisschen mehr Geschmack drin.
[Kiki] Ja, stimmt!
[Hamza] Ne?
[Kiki] Dankeschön!
[Hamza] Bitte!
[Hamza] Hast du toll hinbekommen mein Schatz!
[Kiki] Dankeschön!
[Hamza] Gönnt euch!